the Pentagon's all-star team of weapon
systems from the world's most advanced
fighter plane to anti-aircraft missiles
to the Navy's ship of the future the
Defense Department admits that all of
these and more have been compromised by
Chinese computer hackers in some cases
hackers penetrated the networks of major
defense contractors in others cyber
spies use nanotechnology or orbiting
telescopes to obtain the information
among the weapons designs the Chinese
went after the f-35 fighter the most
expensive weapons system of all time the
Navy's new littoral combat ship which is
designed to operate close to shore the
advanced Patriot missile system and the
Navy's Aegis missile defense system the
v-22 Osprey and the Global Hawk
long-range surveillance drone altogether
the defense Science Board says more than
two dozen weapon systems have been at
least partially compromised defense
contractors won't admit their networks
have been hacked
but Northrop Grumman which makes the
f-35 says the number of attempts to
breach its computer system is increasing
at an alarming rate